- I don't understand the
whole hype with this.
It does make me want to wear Uggs, though.
(upbeat folk music)
- All my white girlfriends
and all my bottom gay friends
like this (bleep).
- I don't like to do seasonal things,
because then when it's gone it's like ...
- [Male] It hurts.
- [Female] A break up.
- I think that there's not
even like, pumpkin in it.
- No (bleep)-ing way
there's pumpkin in this.
- Are they hot?
- First thing, I didn't
know they were hot.
- Dude, have you looked inside of this?
- There's oil at the top of this.
What the (beep), where
did the oil come from?
- Do you think it smells like weed?
It smells like weed.
- [Male] Yeah.
Maybe that's why everyone likes it.
- Cheers.
- Ooh, eh!
- Oh, I like that actually.
- I want to, like, buy a fire
and like, a bear skin rug.
- I want to watch Gilmore Girls
because this is making me so basic.
- Ugggh.
- To me, this is what pumpkin tastes like.
- I don't taste pumpkin.
- Doesn't taste at all like real pumpkins.
- I think you'd have to tell
me that this is pumpkin.
- I'm in seventh grade, and
this is Bath and Body Works,
and I just drank it.
- It smells good.
- This is the perfect, just,
coffee where you just go ...
- Yeah, yeah, exactly!
(laughs)
And Hocus Pokus is on the Disney Channel.
- It's like pumpkin pie, chewed up,
like, spat into like, a coffee machine.
- Could you have this everyday?
- No, I'd feel like a lard ass.
- It's just, like, a new way to, like,
get people excited about
something that they
probably, if it was available all year
it wouldn't be that exciting.
- But I kind of can't stop drinking it.
Like, I'm like, "Oh,
I'll have another sip,
I'll have another sip."
- Got to be honest, I might get this.
I'm basic, A-F.
- I think there's better ways to
get into the festive, fall spirit.
- Go carve a pumpkin.
- Jump in a pile of leaves.
- Cuddle up, and don't get pregnant.
(laughter)